you work with Julia really closely last
year and she isn't exactly on the show
still did she talk to you going in
season two about where the direction was
going did you guys keep in touch between
seasons about what you're gonna do and
which want to express for this season
yeah we definitely talked periodically
you know I think more so than anything
julia has just been so encouraging she
really hasn't you know been going around
telling anyone what to do I think she's
just been you know it was just a really
positive uplifting you know life for us
she actually stopped by the set one day
when we were filming this season and I
don't know just just crazy to see her
come back you know such a light always
so you know she's she's a cool close
friend hopefully she's proud of what
we've done it was hard for me to come
down here
there's no one I can it's hard for me to
talk about this I'm sorry
so where do we find Walter this time
around when we start off
what's his mindset like I think that
when season two starts we start with a
very curious Walter you know Walter
that's unsure of certain things that's
happened in the past he has a lot of
questions and slowly he goes from you
know having these questions to getting
these answers and you know and then
wanting more you know ultimately one and
two to right some of the wrongs it's a
place where first season I was like the
people around me will keep me a secret
like we were in a movie and everyone
knew we were in a movie except for me
we've had an opportunity in the last few
years to work with like real powerhouses
and Janelle Monae is one of those
performers that transcends like any kind
of label what was it like working those
scenes with her being with her on set I
loved it I was a big fan of Janelle's
music even before getting to work with
her we had met a couple of times in the
past and you know I got to express that
and you know so there's been a mutual
respect between us and and when they
call me and told me that she had been
cast honestly I really kind of thought
of a better person for that role you
know just seeing some of the acting
stuff she was starting to do moonlight
etc you know I just need this she was
special and I just knew that this show
would give her a real opportunity to
display her her her her gifts and so I
think the world would be pleasantly
surprised with what she doesn't it if I
did something wrong I have no idea what
it is
we're on set with somebody whose work is
like so contagious like I do have find
yourself stopping yourself from becoming
her songs Loki under your breath like
there's plenty I may have had a day or
two like that don't sell it
[Music]